we got the Xbox series X PlayStation 5
and of course a gaming PC all nicely
connected to this insane but beautiful
display this is the BenQ Mobius ex480 uz
and I gotta tell you thing bigger is
definitely better
um
[Music]
this is probably the most over-the-top
gaming monitor we've ever used here in
the geek office and yes you heard that
right this is a gaming monitor not a TV
this bad boy here is packed with all the
bells and whistles to get your man cave
or what's the opposite of man cave she
she shed the she shared yes it's HDMI
2.1 ready it's got 120 hertz 0.1 Ms
response time it's got a 90 watt USB
power delivery port and not to mention
this is a 4K OLED panel and it's 48
inches
48 inches that's scary and impressive at
the same time all of this to house your
PC and console it's it's like the
all-in-one ultimate system for you it's
a home theater so with that let's go
through the unboxing we're actually
going to go back in time a little bit to
the first time we opened up this bad boy
and installed it so let's check it out
the growth Suite of this monitor is 24.5
kilograms or about 54 pounds oh we need
some assistance pull it out yeah you
know you hold it no no no no give it
yeah okay okay yeah yeah yeah
and lo and behold where do we start
quick start guide stand back panel plate
mount for the display dude this is huge
man next we have a USBC to USBC cable it
also comes included with a display port
cable DisplayPort 1.4 and of course what
we have here is the USB type B to type a
cables for the two USB ports
and it also comes with HDMI 2.1 cable so
this is 8k ready cables you can see it
over there it says 8K show the cables 8K
huh
and we also have the power cable for the
display it doesn't look like we have a
brick so that is a plus for me man no
brakes just instant cable two the
monitor wonderful we also have the
remote thank you remote very classy no
with all that out of the way it's time
to uh stand it's time to open this ah
I'm just gonna put it on every stable
I'm sure she doesn't like there we go
okay
here we go it's all bubble wrap flip it
flip it flip it flip it yeah so okay
I'll leave you pool
hi
so now that we've flipped it okay it's
gonna make it a lot easier we're just
gonna follow the quick start guys step
one is to take the stand
take
the back panel
stamp it like so all right simply enough
like so it these parts are pretty light
okay and by like 32 inch biceps come on
screw it screw tight there we go and
then place it like so
all right remember we had a screwdriver
and some set screws we have to screw all
the four screws in
a few moments detail whoo
we put on the back panel
voila
it's a lot of things so I'm back
but man is looking good all right so now
time to get down to the minutia of
things this is the i o port and what
we're looking at is two USB 3.2 ports
yes we've got the USB type B Port so
that goes into your PC so that you can
use the two USB 3.2 ports we also got a
USB C Port which also has a 90 watt
power delivery you've also got a
DisplayPort 1.4 and two HDMI 2.1 ports
for all you console users out there
you've also got the spdif out which
basically we don't really use that but
you can use it for your set-top box or
your spdif coaxial
um interface thingamajig
and last but not least a headphone Port
as well now knowing how large this
display is well BenQ has made it very
easy by giving you just the power
outlets directly in to the display
there's no brick no fancy schmancy
gizmos just drop it down and plug it
into your outlet and you're ready to go
and we're gonna do just that we're going
to add in all our consoles and our PC
and we're gonna see how it performs so
as you can see setting up this monitor
takes at least two or three people for
its size but other than that it's
relatively straightforward to set this
up so one thing right off the bat is
that this monitor is really huge and if
you're planning to get this monitor you
got to make the space for it thankfully
though this display does come with a 200
by 200 millimeter Visa Mount so you can
mount this on a monitor stand if you
wish now once we've powered it on you
can just tell how good the quality of
the display is and not only that the
overall aesthetic really screams for
that Gamer look and Vibe right with the
orange accents on the legs the four LEDs
at the back that you can actually play
around with with the colors and the
effects like Spectrum weaving and even
Morse code to even say I love you
I love you I love you for more personal
touch you are already looking at a very
solid and sturdy build quality here and
the cherry on top is the four sided slim
bezels that really gives it that whole
guide into gaming design now what I can
say about this is that it's absolutely
perfect for those who enjoy big screens
and those who like to sit back and enjoy
some console gaming and you know what
it's perfect for movies as well so you
guys are gonna love this now it does
beat a 4K TV in some cases because you
have a 120 hertz screen right here with
0.1 Ms gray to gray response time and on
top of everything else it also has AMD
freesync premium which benefits
competitive Gamers for a very smooth and
high frame rate experience now they
would definitely take full advantage of
this display and its size here's more
details for all you pixel peepers out
there you're looking at the DC ip3 98
OLED panel with 450 15 minutes of peak
brightness and 10 bit color display for
complete immersion in true detail So I
myself find it very hard to find for in
this display it just delivers your
pretty much colorful and vibrant visuals
very smooth blacks while retaining
resolution and sharpness at this screen
size on the surface it might just be a
huge display covered with the gamer
aesthetic but you'll be surprised at
what's under the hood as well now Banky
wants you to have the No Frills just
power up your console or PC and dive
right into gaming and with its quick
on-screen display to quickly tune your
game audio and visual settings and the
best part even saves those settings
depending on the sources you have thanks
to this thing called scenario mapping of
course you also have HDR in the form of
emulated HDR which is called hdri now
hdri is benq's proprietary HDR
technology which helps Elevate the
already very solid display by
fine-tuning some of the HDR settings to
balance out the contrast between the
dark and light areas and adjust the
overall brightness by responding to
ambient light conditions so yes this has
like an ambient light sensor and it will
change the brightness according to how
light shifts throughout the day and so
on it's actually pretty intuitive and
I'm enjoying it so far because the other
day I get less eye straight and I can
game for much longer so speaking of hdri
there's two modes one is for gaming and
one is for pretty much you know watching
Netflix or watching movies and they both
work very differently so in most cases
when you have a display that just has
HDR what happens is that you have some
levels of overexposure happening in the
image itself and you just lose the
immersion with hdri like game hdri for
this instance it kicks in to find that
perfect balance between contrast and
detail now on top of that you can also
fine tune it with the light tuner
setting along with the hdri which offers
more or less gradations and you can also
increase or decrease the details in the
contrast areas as well now the BenQ
Mobius ex480uz also comes with preset
color modes for game genres like RPG
games racing games and you know even
like FPS as well for instance FPS color
mode the screen will lift the darker
area so they can actually see players
more visibly and with gaming aside
there's also Cinema HDR which is useful
for like a home theater experience I
would say so watching movies and TV
shows appear more flat on standard HDR
right so with Cinema hdri it just makes
the view experience even more immersive
[Music]
oh bro it's like the movies the
immersion rule just walk to everywhere
so wet bro this movie
the colors are more saturated especially
in the green blue and like CN colors
cyan CN cyan colors watching movies also
a very cool experience because if you
don't have quality speakers you don't
have to be worried because these guys
are actually pretty darn good
so wet bro the ex480 use that is
equipped with 2.1 channel speakers with
a 10 watt built-in subwoofer and it's
calibrated by the other Engineers over
at trevolo and what you're getting are
very modest speakers with sound that can
feel pretty much an entire room in fact
it feels this whole okay everybody was
annoyed for a moment
now with that said of course speakers
are more enjoyable when played loud and
after a couple of game sessions and
movies I have to admit that these are
very good sounding speakers coming from
a gaming monitor manager so action
scenes have that low end Rumble to them
dialogues have Clarity and detail and
with gaming you're actually able to
pinpoint where footsteps are coming from
again bankue has given you the control
over its settings and it's worth
pointing out that there are different
audio presets that do sound different
from each other so FPS brings up the
mids and highs for clearer footsteps
racing games have an elevated low to mid
range so you can hear the engine roll
and Rumble and even live pop that
enhances the overall sound staging for
much richer and detailed sound I also
have to say that using a PC on this very
very large display has been an
interesting experience and I thought
having you know two displays to work on
was good enough for me but using this 48
8 inch pieces for having four even five
monitors and I find that having all the
extra real estate is incredibly useful
for working on multiple things at the
same time now of course being up front
and close to the monitor when using a PC
one can suffer neck strain especially
when you're moving about just looking
everywhere so BenQ has given you the
option to actually downscale the screen
size from 32 inches all the way to 22
inches if you prefer that so whether
you're comfortably sitting further back
on the couch to play games or your
console or closing the distance when
working on a PC you're covered in any
viewing distance overall this is
definitely a great monitor that's
catered to Gamers that are looking for a
gaming monitor that can house all your
gaming consoles and PC for an all-in-one
gaming Hub now the banku Mobius ex480
use it is priced at 299 Singapore
dollars which is competitively priced
now as it stands literally the Mobius
ex-480 uz is a formidable 48 inch
monitor that will cover all your gaming
and entertainment needs whether it's
gaining an edge with the 120hz 0.1 Ms
response time or getting Solid Audio
that brings your Dreamcast to life or
even giving you the image quality you
want thank you pretty much has you
covered on all fronts and then some and
if 48 inches is simply too much for you
ha you can also check out the BenQ
Mobius 4K line with their 27 inch
ex2710u and the 32 inch
ex3210u as well alright gonna wrap up
this video if you have any questions do
leave them down in the comments below
and I'll do my best to get to them
follow us on all our social media
platforms and be sure to hit that like
and smash that subscribe button because
it helps us a lot until then stay tuned
for more videos just like this this is
Zaki signing off
more caught man let's go and play Call
of Duty
[Music]